so apparently now i have a criminal
record yes it's true a lot of you have
been outraged
angered and upset uh when i posted the
letter i got from the city of london
police
outlining why i was fined and banned and
they
said literally it was because you didn't
donate ryan i bet you didn't donate
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla as you guys know
look it's just one thing to it brian
gets caught lying again
and the sun is caught rising again guys
two things that are just seem to be
always true these days
listen i don't want to talk about brian
all the time but he keeps telling these
whoppers and honestly you know
nobody else is covering them the news
media is like what you have like like
point five percent of the vote
like of course they're not gonna cover
them so it's up to us to do the due
diligence on this guy and to cover
one of the biggest like sort of laughing
stocks
of the internet and nobody knows it i
feel like our community is the only one
who knows
the ridiculous that is going on
with brian so i feel obligated to keep
this saga going i literally have a
playlist
he's one of the few people that i really
have a dedicated playlist for the london
real saga
it charts the time from when brian rose
was a respected podcaster
who had great guests on all the way to
this fall
and this is just another in a long
series of just like
he's tearing down his old reputation so
again you just saw it
he was uh telling people that he has a
criminal record
i have a criminal record but the reddit
caught you brian apparently this fine
which he uh conveniently only showed
part of you see brian benedict rose
funny
middle name by the way benedict and at
first many people
took this for what it looks like which
is a criminal
complaint some kind of criminal record
but in actuality you go look at the
details
and this man is lying in actual fact
this was a
standard 200 pound penalty
which according to the website on this
it's payable within 28 days and then if
you pay the fine within 28 days
you won't be prosecuted for a criminal
offense
buddy you got a speeding ticket
and you're freaking out and crying
victim
the level of the grift has just gone on
so
far look at this i now have a criminal
record and underneath that it says that
arrest and detention could be considered
as battery
what are you talking about he was never
arrested he said he was arrested he was
never arrested he was pulled over they
said hey
actually you can't do this and he's like
hey hey i feel like this is political
they're like no actually this is like
the entire
city right he's like what i'm not doing
anything i'm not doing anything i'm not
doing anything remember when you're
walking around
flouting the law and then tried to pin
it as like oh i was just going around
innocently
and they pulled me over as a political
move guys
i don't believe that brian rose is so
dumb
that he really doesn't understand how a
simple uh
offense works like he can't read i don't
believe brian
is illiterate i don't believe that about
him i think
this guy is your class a grifter he's
been revealed for what he is
and finally he's just really leaned into
it i mean can you imagine
first of all saying you were arrested
when you weren't arrested you were
pulled over
right it's like getting pulled over by
the cops and going guys you'll never
believe
i was thrown in the pin for like you
know for 24 hours like no you weren't
second of all criminal offense well guys
i have a criminal record now no you
don't brian
quit trying to be hard you're trying to
be like pretend like you're the tough
guy getting censored you got a small
fine
which by the way he's probably made far
more in donations to cover the fine than
the original fine
has ever caused all this cry of
censorship and yada yada they're
shutting me down
you know why he's doing it right he's
doing it because the supporters money
comes
flowing in when he says that in other
news of the terrible things brian's been
up to
he went to the graveyard i don't know if
you noticed he was in the graveyard in
the
uh cemetery at that last picture right
in that graveyard he went around i guess
this was another day i guess he walks
around the graveyards a lot
but he goes there to apparently reflect
on what the dead
could do better i'm not even kidding i
always like going by these graveyards
and thinking about the people and the
lives they lived and
quite frankly always asking myself um
if they're wondering what else they
could have done what the
what's going who
are you who does that
you're going to a graveyard broadcasting
it first of all and going i
wonder i wonder if they could have
hustled a little bit
i wonder if they wished they had taken
the brian rose
broadcast yourself accelerator i wonder
if they had
wished they had donated more could they
have done
um how much uh harder they could have
pushed
um how much more they could have donated
how much more they could have served
so it always makes me think what do
these people regret doing
and then it reminds me not to have those
same regrets
these old failures over here i'm not
going to be like them
who i don't know listen i don't want to
take him in bad faith here
i think maybe there's a positive way to
spin that message
but it comes off so narcissistic and
tone deaf
and that's the point we're at with brian
i mean it's like everything he's done
does is colored by what he keeps doing
where he keeps playing this game where
he's like this persecuted guy
who's going to graveyards going yeah
lose or sit over there
it's like who is this man at this point
he's completely transformed
honestly he's unrecognizable i want you
to comment below if you used to be a
london reel fan
do you recognize the modern brian rose i
would love to know
but yeah i really wanted to call this
out thanks to the reddit sleuths who
figured this out
um this is not a criminal record this is
a small like parking ticket and brian
rose is being a gigantic baby i play
more of the clip
for you guys because there's a million
clips that have been dying to play but
brian rose mr free speech has started to
take down videos that play any of his
content so i can't do that anymore
but uh that's all for now thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
[Music]
one
wake up and smell the coffee